[Music]
yeah this one launches the nostalgic
feels it's the first commercial for
super smash brothers on the Tendo 64 now
it's a common plays idea to see a
favorite lovable characters beat the
shit out of each other
but back then seeing these cuddly cute
ball skip was pretty shocking when it
was followed by this suddenly it's
Joaquin Phoenix from gladiator looking
over an enchanted bloodbath Nintendo
what I like is before you realize it's
all going this direction it just looks
like Mario snapped at Yoshi did you have
a flashback to when he was a baby and
Yoshi failed to protect him
that's your third boys to whoever threw
Pikachu twice by the way skipping if
they were just gonna fight is it like a
Clockwork Orange where Mario knew he was
gonna jack them up I was calm on the
outside but thinking all at the time
so not was you see the general are
saying what the dough and what not to do
when Ivy did what to do could you just
get revenge by dropping him off another
cliff we know the Yoshi species are like
socks to you ultra violent as hell but
pretty funny too this commercial hits
hard in the laughs only on Nintendo 64
[Music]
hey kids wanna eat your bling seek help
and done seek a ring pop will you wear
my ring
[Music]
it's a catchy jingle and a typical setup
but it is one of those few commercials
that have me constantly asking the
question what happened after I know I
know these are just playful scenarios to
set up jokes but what if they didn't
cutaway help the rest of these scenes
play out will you wear my ring seriously
where's the ring though well I you kept
a box behind your back saying will you
wear my ring you do not screw with a
girl when it comes to that well well I
got some tootsie rolls if you're
interested in any of turn it around and
wear it on the inside what does that
have to do okay what the hell you told
me there was a ring I thought I was
fighting the school bully I was pissing
myself with fear was all just a pun for
edible jewelry
here's your Pop
[Music]
my wife is a toddler and tiara is
scaring Julie are you giving candy on
your walkway clothes
you better not chubby thighs
nevertheless it's a cute commercial for
a cute product believe it or not there
was a time when the funniest commercials
you could watch or milk commercials yeah
in the early 90s milk sales were down so
the California milk processor board
hired renowned advertising agency
goodbee silverstein and partners to make
milk well kind of cool but how do you do
that
it's milk I mean this was their
advertising campaign before clearly
didn't have that big in effect but with
the catchphrase of only two words got
milk
suddenly milk was hilarious good milk if
Santa didn't get some with his cookies
he'd steal your friggin tree think
you've died and gone to heaven not when
you have giant cookies and no cartons of
milk to wash it down with
got milk the best ones often tricked you
so you didn't even know you were
watching a milk commercial until the
very end one of them you think is an
Oreo commercial trying to find a name
for the product cookie but when an
advertiser wants to drink down his mouth
full what about you Hurley
well when that case wasn't it good that
he didn't have milk still better than
this another it's particularly cruel
making you think it's a tricks
commercial
[Music]
next time try a better costume than
Kenny from half-baked these ads were so
popular they were even being mentioned
by God milk
CGV ginger China's but by far the best
is the one that started it all an
obsessed fan of Alexander Hamilton and
still obsessed makes a peanut butter
sandwich when a radio calling contest
asks for $10,000 who shot him
who shot Alexander Hamilton in that
famous duel all right let's go to the
phones and see who's out there mmm Oh
for $10,000 whoa excuse me I'm sorry
[Music]
got milk my god is that brilliant by far
the greatest got milk commercial and
probably one of the greatest commercials
of all time I mean it's absolutely
genius
what the hell directed that no no that's
right critic your Bey weave heavenly
Christ you directed this masterpiece oh
sure but I don't really see it as a
masterpiece how can't you it's one of
the most famous commercials of all time
yeah but that was the old bay the one
that still put out quality and new
things
today's Bay would just do the usual shit
in fact in honor of its 24th anniversary
very random number lively shot the
commercial to reflect my current style
you didn't I did you broke what wasn't
broken
I prefer blew up at both work take a
look that was annoying boy says no no no
no no for two hours and now for today's
sexy question who was responsible for
writing The Legend of King Arthur
I know the answer it was transformers
covering up a drunk Merlin oh that's so
correct you win now I'll shower and milk
against a blazing sunset in slo-mo give
me a sec let it drink a Bud Light what
white is awesome so not only did that
make no sense but you let a product
placement get in the way of another
product placement oh you're too kind
I'm just gonna pretend in a parallel
universe you're listening to me I've
been giving that a lot lately well even
though times change
great commercials always last oh no this
was an ad for a department store called
zellers and well it's cool to get Batman
and Robin in there the way that
represented is kind of odd attention
attention family thanks honey time
prizes on Joe okay I don't know why the
Beck cape has an announcer but he does
not sound very excited to be said
announcer I won't be ecstatic if Batman
pick me for that job you unenthusiastic
dick Joker's
Wow I know the Joker's supposed to be
excitable but hummingbirds made out of
jell-o don't move like that Julian I'm
all cartilage listen only observers are
you protected by and what's up with
Batman's voice it sounds more like his
grandpa on 1920s radio he's pulling a 22
schedule only observers are you
protected by the law of Toyland nobody
keeps sellers prices on toys nobody yeah
that's great
is this crime really Batman or Joker
worthy I feel like this was at the lower
end of anarchy and chaos
Hot Wheels are just a dollar seventy
seven each next I'll tell them that's
Walmart's prices are suitable at best
suitable the weirdest right and stimpy
animation close out what was already a
surreal bat experience you're protected
in cellars because the lowest price is
the law my imaginary spine I don't have
odd to say the least but still contains
a lot of energy for a few yucks
Batman what it's Zellers Robin ain't
bringing his a material to this move The
Pretenders here's a cute idea
I think honestly it's kind of weird
there the PERT Enders cats that can't
get adopted so they disguise themselves
as other animals you know because a
toucan and a duck have a better chance
of getting bought over a cat we have to
work with this dumbass pun this is the
best we could do in it brilliant isn't
it just your basic a stall you can get
anywhere but throw a two-cent mask on
him and suddenly there's a creeping
story I was blacklisted during the
McCarthy era the only vice grips for me
if they think I'm a bunny how dumb are
you a mouse it's a cat
hey mice this was such a weak-ass idea
they had to downplay their toy
appearance and Burger King meals what do
you think it could be it might be
bleeding linguini yeah pretenders would
be impressive if you thought you were
getting linguine
were you dropped it's the pretenders
more fun cats who pretend to be a dog a
doc a mouse and a bunny honestly I
prefer the linguini what are you on a
little too complicated for my taste but
I guess it's adorable
don't tell okay why are you helping the
pretenders from fisher-price
each sold separately bucket of rainbows
what the hell you know sweaty muscles in
front of dry ice can sell idiots
anything Oh trust me I know
check out this ad for an unimpressive
toy called the Eliminator a plastic
knife that doesn't cut hyped that is
literally the same thing I think your
sister in college will get better use
out of that than you yeah I have one of
those too it's called a flashlight it's
a flashlight again a flashlight I think
I'm putting together who this toy was
intended for you didn't even name 7/7
was complimenting yourself hello and
they're cheap Taiwan plastic one of the
we cast weapons are on that thing Louis
the ice cream scoop the electric
toothbrush and the thing the father
tried to sell in gremlins cool
a little funny for its cheesiness but
still lame-ass toy if you can't find it
it's because it's also your mom's dildo
mr. Wolverton there's a mr. the Frog
here to see you mr. Warburton okay I
know the Muppets have had their ups and
downs in the past but what the hell are
they doing here is it true you're
bringing out a giant crumpet
yes but well sir you have given me a
fantastic idea for a muppet extravaganza
a giant crumpet that's giving you the
idea for a muppet extravaganza you ain't
kidding look at the size of this
production me wrong it's impressive
funny and the Muppets are great but it's
freaking crumpets so it rhymes with
Muppet great it's still just a goddamn
British pastry it really doesn't deserve
this much attention imagine there was a
product called Hobbit condoms would they
be like our show bond and so now we're
doing this some of it even seems out of
character like there's a friggin Muppet
death on screen watch
[Music]
it's not like a safe falls on them real
quick no you see that thing struggle
while being devoured it's kind of
gruesome oh god no I'm the last of my
kind
oh sweet Jesus that's where Skeeter want
it even ends on well kind of a raunchy
note no true you're the world's biggest
okay I do not want to think of Miss
Piggy sexual assaults just because
you're a woman and a pig doesn't make it
any less Harvey Weinstein ich do pigs in
space now pigs in jail again the
commercials fine I guess but why float
this much money into a lavish production
for British crumpets have things really
gotten that bad for the Muppets crumpets
goddamn crumpets are you shitting me
with the freaking Muppets not
Teletubbies my grandfather was an old
Jewish socket he came to this country to
uphold our the Frog name you don't give
me better deals you're letting a
generation of fabric down just think I
see you want me to think about it well
think about this Larry my banjo rainbow
connecting to what's left of your bowl
Nancy
yes mr. f could you run down to beanies
and give me another six-pack of hopping
frog beer don't you think you've had
enough mr. F I'll tell you when I've had
you washed up
and do the rainbow fade Wow
I got really depressing on that one
didn't I well here's hopefully a more
chipper commercial to make you feel
better
you were still thinking about Kermit
weren't you look here's something more
chipper a delightful little doggy little
guy oh yes you um you're so adorable
they're just kind of keeping the camera
on you aren't they yeah just let me say
anything that here at any announcers
guess they're just thank you on your
cuteness okay I can go with that
oh yes please give us a pound we'll have
to pull the trigger
[Music]
what and fluffy shit was that is this a
terrorist hostage video for Petsmart
this is even for art spc a but let me
look that up an animal welfare charity
in Britain now of course when you're
doing crumpets you're all Muppets and
dancing but when you're doing PSA you're
telling dogs new Canada just listen to
the wording they use in this please give
us a pound
we would have to pull the trigger are
they trying to get across the message
that if you give them the money they'll
be able to stop cruelty to animals
was that what they were trying to get
across while you failed miserably yeah
it doesn't come across that way at all
they literally say give us a pound or
we'll pull the trigger I would think
this is a gritty reboot of cats and dogs
directed by Christopher Nolan they don't
even say when RSPCA stands for it well
in my mind it stands for really shitty
puppy crucifying assholes this got such
a negative backlash that they cut down
the PSA and had a kid saying how much is
that doggy in the window while answering
how much a dog really does cost yeah
don't forget to include the funeral you
sick shits in fact that ironically
contradicts the last one they did where
this one says don't spend the cash if
you can't afford it the other one says
give us the cash or you'll see Benji's
brains okay I'm done with this one it's
horrible it doesn't get the point across
it's just disturbing please show me a
different one to watch
[Music]
come on come on maybe I won't think of
the PSA pound puppies pound give us a
pound we'll pull the trigger I'm sorry
you two but I need time it's the Mickey
Mouse talking phone ah the Mickey Mouse
phone I think a lot of kids at this kid
you are way too young to be into Mickey
Mouse watching your body also you sound
relatively disinterested in it to be
fair it's better than this obviously
confused kid says that to a character
phone that's like playing Mario Brothers
and saying this has nothing to do with
plumbing that was Mickey Mouse huh
sounds more like a drunken old lady
shouting obscenities don't laugh at her
it only makes her drink more okay I
sound nothing like Snow White but I'm a
woman that should fool you at this age
that was one of the marshes from Mars
Attacks three out of three wrong that's
pretty impressive let's be honest this
project would be a lot more fun if they
brought in even more interesting Disney
characters there's a good variety you
can choose from this is judge Frodo by
sexual lust for gypsy girls had by age
birds like Harold's fire hello we're the
cast from Song of the South
still a neat idea for a toy does not
advertise very well Tiger looked arcade
action in the palm of your hand I think
that's a lie
games like Mega Man fight your way
through eight stages of play as you
attempt to defeat the villainous dr.
wily Wow
what is this one whole bit games like
mm2 Billy Lee returns as you use your
incredible acrobatic yeah what acrobats
are those extending one arm and one leg
while your dick magically disappears
look at this it's so lame they have to
focus on the kids moving around because
there's no excitement in the game itself
if you saw any kid moving like this
while playing a tiger game you think he
was having an epileptic episode but beat
the ultimate villain the black gato bomb
it's so jacked up he gets excited about
golf
yeah there's friggin golf but not just
any golf lee Trevino's fighting golf so
you know they need the real shit choose
between two levels of difficulty as you
select your own golf clubs control the
strength of your swing and the direction
of the ball I'm already asleep hearing
these exciting selections and this kids
hopping all over the place
video excitement in the palm of your
hand yeah that looks like a Kipling
handheld Golf over there also available
with the Batman afterburners super
sprint and 5 in the quest on those dates
this has lead Trevino's fighting dog and
yes your jealousy arouses me is you
completely hold of championship gold dum
ad for a dumb product nothing much to it
Tiger Ltd video game
video excitement in the palm of your
hand Hey look ball sacks sucked off a
fire hydrant that's too crazy for even
me to make a joke about it I don't think
this could get more abstractly perverted
up spoke too soon Ice Cube all sacks are
where it's at where it population okay
you know what these commercials are
innocent enough I shouldn't read too
many of you windows it's immature and
it's been done to death
I should really just grow the hell up so
let's move on to the next one it's a
family game fun for children and for
adults it's exciting on you make
strategic offensive and defensive moves
then try to bust your balls Oh Kevin
Spacey likes to play this one more
[Music]
you know what you're doing I know what
that wink means you know what you're
doing Oh Buster you know it'd be easier
to get through if the narrator didn't
solve evade every time he talked about
it Buster ever adults it's exciting try
to bust your opponent's balls
here's tongue on that one a great new
game from ego you know what though I
think I did okay yeah every year there's
always a commercial like this with heavy
sexual innuendos and you know what I
think I stay pretty mature pat myself on
the back this year I'm patting myself on
the back I'm the bigger person I thought
why don't you call the new water no no
no I am NOT saying a thing I am NOT
saying a thing you hear me
not a god damn word but you think way
too highly of me if you think I'm not
gonna re-edit this in a humorous way
[Music]
that's anything
the wonderful wife could like that now
the word final verdict whose inator is a
fine commercial it just has the
misfortune of coming across the wrong
way I mean cut away your green goblin
deck oh my god this Atari commercial is
amazing I really mean amazing it's
actually so good it's hard to believe
it's real
Hey yeah you look like a real jerk I
already believe every commercial should
start off that way so what you doing
well Buffy Buffy
Biff jr. and I are going on a Sunday
Drive oh no you ain't
you're gonna play
[Music]
what even is pole position sure it's
bought Angeles really crappy I don't
care it's bought I have no idea why an
explosion change the logo on that side
and I don't care Oh
I went through pull palsy Shawn
[Music]
from Atari it'll bust your crap and
leave skid marks
oh my god that was amazing
that was so amazing it's like suburban
commando if it was suburban commando
it's just phenomenal the comedy the
energy the over-the-top 80s of it all is
pure perfection and I think at the heart
of it is that guy that punk ass narrator
he is just so aggressively random he
calls this dude a jerk and then he
rewards him and he's so hostile to this
quiet non-threatening family I have no
idea what this guy would do in everyday
situations all I can say is I want to
see this guy style of madness in every
commercial you look like real jerks so
what you doing oh well we're going to a
family reunion up you're fighting
dinosaurs now watch it
[Applause]
hey shark watch it down oh I just made
pie actually it sounds really nice
it's apple pie that's my favorite would
you like a slice please
that's delicious
oh thank you you're the secret
ingredients not to break down the boo
but I think I killed your entire family
what yeah I gave one to a t-rex of
skills and killed another one of the
melted another's in space I killed your
dog pretty much everything you cherish
does God well I'm sorry I get carried
away sometimes
but hey have you ever played Atari pole
position no it's a lot of fun you should
try it okay okay well I'm gonna go away
and be a voice you had really nice bye
sorry I killed your family
it's really good Wow again I won't
really darken that one really dark I'm
the Nostalgia Critic and I don't know
why I look forward to this every year
[Music]
[Applause]
goddamn crumpets are you shitting me
with the freaking Muppets not
Teletubbies
try to bust your opponent's walls
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing Big
Brothers Big Sisters for more than a
hundred years Big Brothers Big Sisters
has operated under the belief that
inherent in every child is the ability
to succeed and thrive in life as the
nation's largest donor and volunteers
supported mentoring Network Big Brothers
Big Sisters makes meaningful monitored
matches between adult volunteers and
children and communities across the
country they develop positive
relationships that have a direct and
lasting effect on the lives of young
people their mission is to provide
children facing adversity with strong
and enduring professionally supported
one-to-one relationships that change
their lives for the better
forever if you look at their site in
their YouTube channel you can see all
the people trying to create hopeful
futures for countless kids and you can
play a big part in that click on the
link and show your support for the
children of the future
[Music]
you